all right we're gonna get started with
the the more serious news that Elon Musk
actually just dropped and there's some
uh news related to this Elon said any
account doxing real-time location info
of anyone will be suspended as it is a
physical safety violation this includes
posting links to sites with real-time
location info posting locations someone
traveled to on a slightly delayed basis
isn't a safety problem so it's okay so
the big story today that's trending like
crazy is Elon Jet and all of these left
us are like I can't believe Elon banned
Elon jet he said he believed in free
speech Free Speech means you can share
public information Elon just posted this
only about 20 minutes ago last night a
car carrying Lil X in La was followed by
a crazy stalker thinking it was me who
later blocked the car from moving and
climbed onto the hood legal action is
being taken against Sweeney and
organizations who supported harm to my
family
so this is crazy here's the story from
CNN
Twitter suspense account that tracked
musk's private jet despite Billionaire's
Free Speech pledge oh Free Speech pledge
they say Twitter uh on Wednesday
suspended an account that tracked the
location of his jet despite his
commitment of free speech blah blah blah
Twitter later restored the Elon jet
account Wednesday evening after the
company posted a new set of edicts that
appeared to be designed specifically to
justify the removal of the jet tracking
account the move comes after musk has
reinstated previous Twitter rule breaker
rule Breakers the Elon jet account run
by Jack Sweeney a 20 year old Florida
College student used publicly available
flight tracking information to build a
Twitter bot that tweeted every time
musk's Gulf Stream took off and landed
at an airport the last post from the
account prior to the suspension showed
musk's jet taking off from Oakland
California on Monday and landing in Los
Angeles 48 minutes later
Sweeney woke up Wednesday morning with a
message from Twitter saying he'd been
banned now here's what I'm wondering was
this it
was it actually Lil X flying on the
plane and then a lunatic seeing the
information shows up starts harassing
Lil X and then I mean this is not this
is not a fight that elon's on so this
this this goes beyond just uh doxing
elon's jet this wasn't about Elon this
is a private jet which can be used by
many people can be rented out can be
commissioned and because of that very
serious uh harm nearly came to an
individual I also want to mention that
one story where what was it that rapper
you mentioned this before the show surge
that rapper who was like chilling with
his girlfriend and she posted a picture
of his burger oh yeah pnb Rock that's
right Chicken and Waffles chicken
waffles correct in South uh South
Central and then someone walked up and
just shot and killed him yeah taken it
for his uh he's famous for his chains
wearing a lot of chains around him and
someone just felt like it was their time
to take them yeah so what do you guys
think I kind of agree with this policy I
think you should not be doxing doxing is
Real Time exposing you know someone's
personal information or private
information I guess you would call it
not like what like what hair color even
things like that like what their name is
what their address is what their phone
number is what they look like those kind
of data in real time to people you don't
know is a form of doxing but the thing
is elon's got to specify what real time
means because is it five minutes ago is
that still considered real times at nine
minutes ago like when is it now no
longer real time we were we were talking
about this uh Ian broads up before the
show when we went to New York to check
out the ads we put up in Times Square
Ian took some pictures we're gonna post
them and I was like wait just wait a few
minutes well yeah I waited like 20
minutes we changed locations before I
put the picture up because we were
standing right where I took the picture
and that was a smart move you never know
real time you know well considering that
rapper store the chicken and waffles
yeah seriously makes a lot of sense
don't dangle your gems in front of the
hungry and poor like
yeah don't show unnecessary data you
don't don't leave things in plain sight
in your car when you go in to the store
you know it's valuable it's a good point
but it was like the analogy was very
esoteric yeah it's like most people
don't have gems to dangle but right but
Ian's got a big pile in front of them so
like like don't leave your phone and
play in sight in your car when you get
out and go into the store stuff like
that don't tempt Faith yeah right don't
don't bring all your fancy dye to a game
shop unless you want people to to lust
for them and I think doxing is a form of
tempting fate you're like saying it you
know I'm not saying to do anything but
here's the in phone case you want to
kind of thing yeah look I I I'm in total
agreement with you guys it's the right
policy it's the right call I mean when
folks physical safety is that issue it's
a totally different ball game and mind
you the same critics who are calling you
know complaining about this saying Oh Mr
free speech whatever are the same a lot
of the same folks who are probably
saying misinformation or disinformation
during the pandemic were forms of
violence or that they were threatening
they needed to be taken down they've
lost their they've lost their Baseline
of reality and what's actually a threat
to people and what's not and your
physical location the harm the the
safety of your family and in yourself is
Paramount and so that's absolutely
something that needs to be monitored but
you know misinformation disinformation
it's
ridiculous yet they were take they were
more than happy to cheer that on yeah
the word violence has been taken away
out of context and blown out proportion
like it's calling someone a name even if
it's a nasty name is not violent right
it's not right you know a
and we need to really really be honest
about what real violence is
uh I think in order to use that term
effectively well there's a lot of other
things happening here that are worth
considering uh but there's also some
people reporting that the Elon jet
Instagram account is also being bound on
Twitter and is being prevented from
people uh giving the ability of sharing
that URL uh just a couple days ago Elon
Musk said that he's not going to be
doing any open air car parades anytime
soon as of course A lot of people are
saying that he might be getting Epstein
as it's fair to say that orange man bad
has been replaced with spaceship man bad
and right now the media top uh top level
lawyers a lot of powerful politicians a
lot of intelligence agencies aren't
really happy with him and are putting a
lot of pressure on him to the point
where there's even lawyers right now
going through his application for
citizenship in the United States seeing
if he made a mistake seeing if he lied
so they could try to renounce his U.S
citizenship which is crazy that's not
true is it I I believe so some random
woman tweeted that and everyone was just
like why wouldn't it be true especially
with how how much their grasping for the
straws when it comes to attacking him I
wouldn't be surprised if this was true I
wouldn't either but some random leftist
propaganda account claiming that they're
trying to revoke Elon citizenship is
very different from
a news report at the very least like you
know we got a video of The Washington
Post people getting laid off and
freaking out and I tweeted you know
what's that word for when you derive
pleasure from the suffering of your
enemies and uh so we get it we get it
shot him but um I still would be like
some random blue check saying it versus
an organization putting their weight
behind it not like I trust them a whole
lot they'll probably twist and lie about
it but there's got to be some evidence
well I I you know I think I think you're
right
um and uh but at the same time when we
look at all the high level pressure
tactics that are going against Elon it
wouldn't surprise me if people are doing
this not putting their face behind it
yet because it's more about sending a
threat it's more about trying to harass
someone it's more about trying to
intimidate someone and I think that's
why this news was shared uh so widely
today and talked about as significantly
as it was because I I I truly do see uh
them grasping at the straws here and
trying to figure out any reason to try
to get him and try to stop him from
doing what he's doing because as we
mentioned here May many times on this
show he's changing the game here he's
creating a situation where people are
finally able to speak freely this
changes everything powerful people the
only thing that they have is the
consensus is the only thing that they
have is people's ignorance especially
when they commit all these crimes
against populations so when you have a
man promising to get rid of all of that
that's a huge threat against them and
this is why I think he's taking his
safety more seriously than ever before I
hope Elon if you're listening you gotta
if you're gonna subvert the Empire you
got to do it subtly if you tell them
your plans before you do it that's what
JFK kept doing kept telling him that
he's going to disband the CA and the CIA
and and then they you know come out and
they can stop you if you let if they
know what you're going to do I don't so
subtlety and decentralization I don't
think he's revealed his plan I I I kind
of feel like there's there's a couple
memes going around about how Elon is
very much in line with the the world
economic Forum on many many issues uh
Ubi being one of them that he's got
Tesla factories in China and that he's
praised the Chinese Communist Party in
the past
you know look the dude may agree with us
on some key issues like Free Speech but
I don't think he agrees with us on a lot
of issues you know I got a uh uh I saw
on YouTube Hassan uh [ __ ] the leftist
made a video called Tim Poole confronts
Elon Musk where he actually says it's an
unironic like of a tweet from Tim Poole
because I tweeted out that that gag
where I said you know I used to think
neural link was scary and dangerous but
then Elon bought Twitter and agreed with
me ideologically now I think norlink is
great and want to have my brain plugged
into the machine and so he was like yeah
great but then he got he got mad at me
because I said look I'm screwing around
neural link is great you know but the
putting in your brain interface stuff is
something else he didn't like that but I
think there is something to it when
leftists like that would agree like hey
hey the neural link brain stuff is
probably over the line you know that we
don't we don't we don't want to go there
so I'm like well if that's the unifying
thing and he actually liked to tweet for
me bro I agree you know I can understand
if someone's paralyzed they want neural
link they'll ask for it I don't like the
idea that elon's outright said the goal
of it is human one-to-one AI interfacing
which in my view
erases Humanity but I think that AI is
going to erase Humanity anyway and that
we're probably yeah we're evolving into
some technocratic you know machine first
Society it seems like where it's
inevitably we might Branch off and have
still like you know ludite humans that
don't want they want to live in the
jungle and be away from electricity but
like we're not going to be in this Homo
Sapien form forever as the dominant
species on Earth so I think that we are
becoming I mean we're already kind of
Cyborg and I love the idea of being able
to type with my thoughts and being able
to communicate with my thoughts because
I think way faster than my hands can
type it's true but see that's what you
think is going to happen and what's
really going to happen is you're gonna
you know Phil Phil made a really really
great point about this filibonti last
night he said you get the neuraling they
don't tell you to do anything what
happens is you'll go out and you'll do
something you'll you'll buy a McDonald's
cheeseburger and the neural link
instantly will give you the tiniest
little dopamine hit you won't know why
but you'll just enjoy yourself and over
time those micro hits of dopamine will
start pushing you in a specific
Direction and shaping you into the
person you never chose to be and you
won't even realize you were manipulated
into being a puppet yeah if the code and
the algorithms are not free of the
neural net everything has to be
transparent you need to know why it's
feeding you what dopamine rushes when
what levels and ideally you're setting
those levels yourself
um it will be complete Annihilation for
the species if it is not open source and
free software you need complete
transparency with a technology like this
it's like I mean in a way I was gonna
say it's like running water but we
really don't know what's coming out of
our tap water either so if you think
hacking a computer network is valuable
wait till you can hack a person
like there already is social engineering
a field of you know hacker culture where
people manipulate people but imagine
being able to pull up a keyboard knowing
the code because it's open source then
governments develop exploits there would
be open source patching of these of
these security issues too don't get me
wrong but you're going to see Zero day
attacks you're going to be sitting in
your room and you're going to be like
all right let's do the anti-government
subversive show oh my brain's exploding
then just oh no he got hacked it was
routed through a bunch of ips we can't
figure out who did it you could do it so
like it automatically shuts down if
there's outside interference
um how would it how everything
everything is exploitable so as long as
there's any kind of read write
capabilities someone will find a way to
go into your brain and just mess you up
yeah you thought computer viruses were
bad imagine that in your head when your
computer is is your brain so uh there's
a lot of potential for a lot of things
going wrong here and uh I think
skepticism is our best trend moving
forward so so we have all of these uh
you know Twitter leftists freaking out
they're screaming you know Elon Musk is
doxing people I thought he believed in
free speech and my response is kind of
just like I don't care what you think
because you never agree with free speech
in the first place so get off your high
horse No One Believes you thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored third members only shows
exclusive thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all next time